should I do it for the money as an
entrepreneur I believe that you
shouldn't be in business just to make
money the reason for you doing whatever
company you're doing right now is to do
it because you love it because you're
passionate about it and if you do that
right then the money will come and if
you look at people who start a business
just trying to make money they never do
they give up when it gets hard because
it's not what they were meant to do and
you look at some of the most successful
most famous entrepreneurs of all time
some of the richest people in the world
the reason why they started their
business wasn't because they wanted to
make a lot of money it's because they
had a vision because they had a passion
because they wanted to change the way
something was done and because it could
pour all their energy into something
because they were willing to keep going
even though it got super hard when they
thought about quitting when things
around them were following their life
was was crumbling they kept going
because they loved it so much that's how
they busted through ended up making tons
of money so don't believe it should ever
make a decision just based on the money
this comes as a result of a question
that came in from one of my loyal
viewers Arturo Thank You Artie row now I
spoke with Arturo a little while ago on
a one-on-one chat on on google hangout
and in that video he was telling me
about his business his business is
helping entrepreneurs business people
when the going to Latin speaking country
helping them translate so if you're if
you're stuck you know your car breaks
down on the side of the road or an
emergency happens you can call him up
and he will be your translator to help
guide you back to wherever you need to
go okay so he wrote in to me with a
question and he's basically saying I'm
thinking about potentially changing my
model and I'm looking at working with
organizations where they support where
there's donors in North America who then
give money to kids in Latin speaking
countries and being the bridge and
helping translate between the donors and
the kids and he said it's different at
the program but it could mean more money
coming in what do you think I should do
that's what he wrote it
so Arturo and for everybody watching
again I don't make decision based on
money so maybe this brings in money but
do you feel like this is important do
you love kids is this an important
mission that you feel needs to be solved
if it isn't do it if it's not then don't
you'll find other ways to make money and
I know because when I started this
company as I was selling advertising
revenue it became a way to make money
right the more views I got on a post the
more money I would make so I started
making posts just to get views instead
of caring social what I was writing
about it was just writing to get views
and I got a lot more advertising dollars
but i felt like i was selling my soul
and I grew increasingly dissatisfied and
I didn't like what I was doing as much
in my business anymore and it needed to
change and so now I only take on
projects where where I feel good about
what I'm doing you know companies will
come and you'll throw tens of thousands
of dollars at me and say you know we
want you to appear in this commercial or
we want you to write a tweet about us
and how great we are if I've never used
your stuff if I don't like it if I don't
believe in it I don't care how much
money you're giving me I'm not going to
do it and that should be your approach
so I don't know Arturo the right answer
for you if you should do this or not but
listen to your heart do you love helping
kids do you love helping donors connect
with these kids is that the business
that you want to be in because when we
spoke on the Google+ Hangout that's not
what we talked about and I'm saying that
that's wrong but if you're doing it just
for the money what are your intentions
if you're doing it just for the money
then it's clear don't do it but if
you're doing it because this is
important this is needed you're going to
feel grateful for having done that then
absolutely jump in and if it means
making more money that's great to
believe so those are watching like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
let me know what you think you have a
I met you have a question for your
business leave it in the comment section
below I make a video response and
subscribe to the channel if you like
this video I want to see more thank you
so much and I'll see you soon